hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from round four
of the tata still chess tournament 2022
it's magnus carlsen with the white
pieces against last year's the winner uh
jordan van forest and it's uh really
really a complicated game so let's dive
straight into it magnus uh with the
white pieces opens with knight to f3 he
goes for the red the opening uh we have
d5 g3 and the g6 uh phrase goes for the
uh symmetrical variation here we have
bishop to g2 bishop to g7 and d4 now so
a very nice symmetry on the board knight
to f6 and both players castle now
castles castles and c4 and now uh while
there are some games where black
continued the symmetry with c5 it is
much more natural to play c6 here uh put
more defense to our d5 pawn and we just
continue development but we still have
to figure out how to develop this knight
here obviously you can go to c6 so
probably uh we'll develop it the d7 but
then we block our bishop so maybe we
developed the bishop first then we
developed the knight and so on but
you'll see so b3 magnus says he's going
to fianchetto the uh dark square bishop
as well and now bishop to f5 before
going knight b 37 uh we have bishop to b
to knight b to d7 and now e3 by magnus
we have knights to e4
uh now here you have to
uh you don't have to go knight to e4 you
could also play d captures on c for d
captures on c4 is to move black and play
pretty much at any point uh
throughout the opening uh but uh we will
not see it here so knight to e4 we have
knight to c3 and knight captures in c3b
captures and now bishop
to e4 so usually we say you don't
capture on c3 uh
not on c3 you don't capture if you don't
gain anything so here uh fun foreign
captured on c3 to put the bishop on e4
and here it's actually a really good
piece so queen to e2 magnus develops the
queen connects the rooks and now e6 the
light square bishop is out of the cage
so we can now close it uh and here uh
usually uh rook if the c1 or rook 8 the
c1 is played but magnus goes for a bit
more rare rook f2d1
and now uh we have a5
so here bishop to f1 now magnus is
preparing knight to d2 to kick away the
bishop from e4 and he doesn't want to
allow the trade of the light square
bishop so first bishop to f1 and now we
have bishop captures on f3 so not even
waiting for the for the bishop to get
attacked queen captures on f3 and now
knight to c5 uh putting the knight on a
very very sneaky square because if the
knight is captured of course the bishop
on c3 will hang
and you will not have anything to
contest black's very strong dark square
bishop so here bishop back to e1
and now knight to e4 so using a tactic
to nicely remini to nicely maneuver the
knight over to e4
and now we come to the actual new move
on the game and that is bishop to d3 so
now as of move 17 we have a completely
new game uh the knight is under attack
and we just want to capture it and of
course win this pawn so uh we have f5
defending this uh sort of a sort of a
dutch pawn structure as van forest is
dutch
and here rook eight 8 c1 uh now
preparing some ideas maybe c captures on
d5 and of course uh hoping that black
opens up the c file but that will
probably not be the case uh and here we
have g5
uh saying that uh black doesn't mind
opening up the the position a little bit
as uh it's it's a very closed uh
structure both on the king side and in
the center of the board so you will not
be able to attack that black king so
here we have queen back to e2 by magnus
and g4 now
we have bishop captures an e4 and now f
captures an e4 uh if you play d captures
on e4 then this d5 move can be very
annoying for example captures captures
where we're going to see captures and
now rook to c5 threatening to capture on
d5 and after d4 something like this
because the bishop covers the d4 square
e captures on d4 and we ended this with
black having a lot of pressure on the
king's side but white having the past
d-pawn so white should be should be much
much better here uh so instead we have f
captures on e4 this nicely opens up the
f file and now queen captures on g4 but
also it uh includes sacrificing of a
pawn so queen to e8 when
by black and now c captures on the e5 uh
again c captures on d5 you never want to
play this because then you allow rook to
c7 and this is just terrible for black
so instead we have e captures and e5
this also fixes black's pawn structure
and now rook to c5 puts pressure on the
a5 pawn and now how can black the defend
this spawn well first we have h5 chasing
away the queen from such an active
square queen to h3 and now we have queen
to f7 putting pressure on the f2 pawn so
again you can't go after the pawn
because if the bishop moves we're going
to capture on f2
so queen g2 defending and now we have a4
advancing the pawn and the situation on
the clock is some uh 42 minutes for
magnus and 31 minute for for one for
race uh and here we have b4 now you
could also play rook to a5 that's
possible then we uh sorry about that
then we trade everything captures
captures rook rougest a8 attacks the
bishop and now we can play b4 so
something like this is possible where
black would be left with this uh funny
looking pawn
here on a4 but then again you will
always be able to defend it with with b5
so you could go for this uh but instead
magnus goes for b4 and now we have queen
to d7
now fun forest is ready to advance that
h pawn uh we have b5 magnus that wants
to open up the structure here he wants
to play rook to c1 and put pressure on
the c6 pawn
we have h4 ignoring what's happening on
the queen side that this is the the
correct way to play yeah and now rook d
to c1 now you are threatening to capture
here and now we have rook to f6
defending here but also preparing some
rook to g6 rook to h6 action if the
position opens up so b captures in c6 b
captures and now g4 a very very tricky
move because if it doesn't work then
you're just going to get destroyed here
uh so uh magnus of course wants to play
h3 and have a very solid setup here on
the king side as well and then he's just
gonna base the entire game around the
weakness of the c6 pawn so of course uh
uh vampires doesn't wanna allow that he
plays h3 he gives up another pawn uh
just uh so he prevents magnus from
playing h3 so queen captures on h3 and
now rook a to f8
uh so what do you play here uh queen
back to g2 and then now comes rook to g6
going after the
the pawn here and now you could play h3
but uh it's uh well if h3 the rook will
come at the f3 and it's a very very
passive position for white you're never
getting that queen out of there it's uh
you you're just going to be defending
for the rest of the game so instead
magnus goes g5 with the idea of
advancing the pawn to h4 now this is
really really impressive stuff so rook
to f5 going after the pawn here queen to
f5 would have been a
a bit better for black but we're going
to discuss this in a little bit so here
h4 magnus defends this pawn and now you
want to sacrifice something here it
would be great to sacrifice the bishop
for the g5 pawn the problem is if you
play bishop to f6 uh we can play rook
captures on c6 and then it doesn't work
if bishop captures g5 we just captured
the rook on g6 with check and then of
course white is just completely winning
so instead after h4 bishop to fa display
that doesn't waste the move really
because it comes with tempo then you're
going to play bishop to e7 and then
we're going to sacrifice the bishop for
the g5 pawn so rook 5 back to c2 and now
bishop to e7 now getting ready to
capture this pawn here and there is one
really good move for magnus here and
that is king to f1 while the king is on
f1 there isn't all that much black can
do here but that that is uh easier said
than played
so here magnus plays rook to b2 prepares
the uh double up on the b file and put
some rooks on on b8 and b7 maybe uh both
players are now down to 12 minutes uh
and here we have bishop captures on g5
and bishop captures on g5 is not a great
move as it loses the game for for jordan
uh what you should have played here is
just rook g captures um
uh on g5 and then after h captures rogue
g captures and then we trade queens
queen uh sorry we trade uh everything
for the queen queen captures bishop
captures and then it's queen and bishop
versus two rooks and the bishop uh with
uh pretty much in an equal possession
but uh uh you don't uh like this against
uh magnus or pretty much against anyone
because what if those rooks just come up
the board it looks like you might not be
able to hold this but this was in fact
the way to equality in the actual game
bishop captures on g5 was played and now
magnus plays king to f1 this is the only
move that wins the game but it also
comes with a problem you you have to
continue playing this uh
very very well
and now it doesn't matter what black
plays you're still going to lose because
well
you can't really move the bishop
if you move the bishop you lose the rook
if you play queen d6 to add more defense
to the rook here we're just going to
capture on g5 and after rook captures on
g5 queen h3 and now you don't really
have any sort of a perpetual here
because after queen g4 check rook here
we're going to play queen d1 and now
we're just up a piece and you don't have
an attack if a queen h2 we're going to
play rook c to b1 and well anything you
throw at white white will just move the
king all the way here and the bishop
nicely covers f2 so
there's no problem there so in the game
queen to a7 was played by uh fun for
race uh saying that uh there is
something hidden in the position and in
fact there is uh because this queen a6
check is um uh well a bit troublesome
for white but there is a move that
solves all of this for magnus so uh feel
free to pause the video here and win the
game for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being rated
almost 2900 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show the movie is
king to e2
that's the good stuff this is the only
move that successfully parries the
threat of queen to a6 because now if
queen to a6 we're gonna play king d1 and
after queen to d3 with check we're gonna
block with rook to d2 and now after
let's say queen to b5 there is no way to
continue checking the white king now we
don't capture but rather play queen to
g4 so you had to see all of this in
order to win this game now the rook is
hanging the bishop is hanging and only
after we move the rook we're going to
capture on g5 and now we are just uh
completely winning with white however
after this queen to a7 magnus played
queen to g4 it seems like it's uh it's a
nice addition to the line that we've uh
shown because the queen is already on g4
so the rook is kind of hanging and then
the bishop is hanging but it allows
black to throw in a nice queen to a6
check and now what do you play here uh
well you could move the queen back then
we just go back with queen to c8 so
nothing is happening really if you play
rook to e2 then you're even going to
lose the game because after queen to c8
what do you play here there's no no good
move for white we're threatening rook
captures on f2 check and we're going to
pick up the queen here and you don't
really have anything better you're going
to capture here captures captures queen
captures here and this is now of course
winning for black so magnus played king
the g1 but now again a very tricky
position and uh well you have to play uh
play it very precisely uh jordan plays
rook to g7 and this is just a wonderful
move to find uh because this is hanging
this is hanging but the problem is even
if you
uh somehow give up this rook this rook
will also be attacked by playing rook to
g7 uh the other rook will not get
attacked and you will have a sufficient
counter play uh other than this also c5
is very nice because the queen now
guards the rook here so those are the
two ideas you can consider
but okay in the game rook g7 was played
and now you can't capture the rook if
you capture the rook then it's just
bishop to f4 check and you're lost the
queen covers f1 bishop covers h2 rook
covers g1 and g2 so you only have the h1
square and after h1 queen to f1 will be
checkmate so easy to miss but it is
there uh so after rook the g7 rook the
b8 check was played by magnus but now uh
jordan just blocks this we have bishop
back to d8 opening up a discovery on the
queen here
and now it seems that magnus will have
to give up the queen so rook capture san
diego to check first uh now comes rook
to f8 blocking this uh you don't want to
play king h7 because then rook d7 and
you can't capture the queen you have to
capture the rook uh so instead of course
rook blocks with rook to fate now come
to rook capture sun f8 king captures and
bishop to be for check
but even this is not enough you can't
shake off
the king from defending the rook so king
g8 queen captures on g7 with czech king
captures and now a3 so now we have this
position where magnus has a bishop in
the rook against the queen and uh well
uh if you look at it the only way black
can make some progress or white for that
matter is uh
well impossible uh because you can't uh
get get over the c5 square white has
perfect control of that and you can't
really do anything about this
on the king's idea either even if you
give up this spawn it's still you know
pretty much droish so king to g6 was
played king to g2 king h5 rook to h1 now
adding a defender here and now uh
jordan just finds a nice nice repetition
here he plays c5 and gives up a pawn and
goes for this queen g6 check king f1
queen to a6 check king to g2 you could
also move the king uh to e1 but it
doesn't seem like white will be winning
this game so magnus agrees to a
repetition here king f1 queen to a6
checking g2 and he was in this position
on move 52 that the players agreed to a
draw
uh so uh really really a tough game
there was a win uh in that one moment
for magnus but he had to find not one
move king but rather to move kings with
king to f1 king to e2 uh if and not then
uh well he he will be struggling to get
a draw
as you've seen in the game and uh for
for the last 10 moves uh player players
were extremely low on time uh so uh the
the couple a couple of last moves were
you know made below the 10 minute mark
so this is uh in a really uh very very
uh well uh correct game
uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
this does not help magnus in achieving
his new set goal of reaching 2900 as of
course with any draw he loses rating as
he's the highest rated player here so
now he has one win and three draws in
this tournament but with this uh metric
he he he just loses rating so i think
now he's down like a point and a half
for the duration of the tournament
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it once again congratulations to
everyone who spotted that king f1 king
to e2 maneuver uh i would like to thank
eddie smuchin stephen wentworth louis
bowman frederick witt and lance
weatherly for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event
and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day